read it to you now in which he says my
grandfather was a man
of service honor and great humor he was
authentically himself with a seriously
sharp wit
and could hold the attention of any room
due to his charm
and also because you never knew what he
might say next
he'll be remembered as the longest
reigning consort the monarch
a decorated serviceman a prince and a
duke
but to me like many of you who have lost
a loved one or grandparent over the pain
of this past year
he was my grandpa master of the barbecue
legend of the banter and cheeky right
until the end
he's been a rock for her majesty the
queen with unparalleled devotion
by her side for 73 years of marriage and
while i could go on
i know that right now he would say to
all of us beer in hand
oh do get on with it it goes on to say
so on that note grandpa thank you for
your service
your dedication to granny and for always
being yourself
you will be sorely missed but always
remembered
by the nation and the world megan archie
and i
as well as your future great
granddaughter will always
hold a special place view in our hearts
so there a statement from prince harry
it has also been confirmed that the duke
of sussex
uh is now here in the united kingdom
and that he has safely arrived and is
staying at frogmore cottage
where we're told that he is following
covid19 protocols